roses n roses who was fixing your hair
was that your girlfriend Jules a Flocka
get over here for me come at this mark
okay okay let's dig into how things are
ending Madison has given you an
ultimatum watching this footage back how
do you feel watching it do you feel it
was fair that she kept some things from
you and gave you this decision to make I
don't feel like it was an ultimatum I
don't I think it was her doing what I
asked every girl to do from the very
first night and that was to be honest
with me and share what was ever on their
heart and that's what she did and it
trust me it made it for an insanely
incredibly difficult week for me there's
no doubt about that
but I can't fault her for sharing her
heart are you really in love with three
women you've gotten some criticism for
this yeah I don't I don't know why it's
if I wasn't feeling I wouldn't have said
it so again I've always been a firm
believer a little heart wants what it
wants and I think this experience for
sure is show me there's not just one
soulmate out there I think at some point
of my life I used to think that and yeah
I've definitely been able to give my
heart to more than one person so it's
possible a lot of people were saying why
didn't you push for more on the
accusation that Victoria had broken up
relationships do you wish you'd ask more
questions gotten more clarity on that
because she's sitting there telling you
I don't know what to answer to yeah and
I did and it just unfortunately wasn't
able to air but we had a long
conversation about really what her
relationship was with Marissa and
accusations she was making we talked
about the relationships that that
Marissa it brought up and there's a
reason why I made my decision you know I
wasn't just going off and no no
conversation there we had a long
conversation and in regards to with
Marissa and my relationship that wasn't
very serious at all I'd maybe seen her
for four times throughout the course of
a month it was a lot more serious with
Victoria and so when I heard Victoria
side of the story it was enough for me
to make the decision and I felt good
about it I see exactly what I have in
front of me and it's the most perfect
woman that I have honestly I've always
dreamt of Peter I keep saying that you
make what I call 747 statements the most
perfect girl the best first date ever
how do you say these extreme of things
and not pick you know Hanna and who's
the most perfect girl she is very no
one's perfect but she's very close to
perfect I'm a very passionate dude and
I'm an extremist kind of and so I make
these statements and it comes from the
heart and that's just who I am how does
your season end Peter well if you must
know you guys continued in a couple
weeks if I got who is barb crying about
Peter a lot of people think it's Hannah
brown now coming in possibly drool
Ziploc who knows there's so many I'm
glad you brought up your producers name
she's your producer is she the woman
that you're with right now so many
theories out there right now it's it's
been it's kind of crazy to hear but I
don't know we'll see
[Music]